[Music]
thank you
they are a much loved household pets in
Britain that has been an alarming rise
in dog attacks lately mostly by the
American Bully XL breed if we lost sight
of how dangerous some dog breeds can be
joining me is right at Ed West an
academic and YouTuber Dr Lawrence of
Newport
Ed Lawrence thanks for joining us on
spectator TV now um Ed you've written a
piece this week uh coffee house has been
our most red piece I think about
wonderful um the most dangerous dog
breeder we could ever think of the
American Bully XL um there's been a 50
increase in Hospital admissions in the
UK for dog bites uh what's going on here
can you tell us a bit about it well the
over the last five years and in
particular last two years there's been a
big rise both in fatalities which are
still relatively small but also injuries
and particularly um surgery for uh which
tends to sort of reflect like the most
vicious attacks rather than you know
like hand attacks
um and a huge amounts of this is down to
one particular breed which is related to
um both the Staffordshire Bull Terrier
and the Pitbull the patent with the pit
bulls you know is banned in Britain but
has managed to
um
avoid being classified and then just
Dogs act answers become increasingly
popular and many people will notice
these dogs in their area
um these are kind of very very big like
double or staffy almost in some ways
um they often look very scary and
um the you know the funny thing is that
the background story is that lots of the
people
um who run or that dog Charities and the
Kennel Club are completely in denial
about the the links in breed and attacks
and it is
um and and there have been lots of very
high profile
um
very very horrific dog fatalities in the
last six months and they almost
invariably in fact it all involve this
one particular route
so largely written a big piece about the
American Bully XL I mean it seems like
it's almost come out of nowhere uh
where's this breed come from and why has
it been why is it so dangerous in your
ear
um so the breed seems to have been
imported from America around about three
four years ago
um it really gained popularity I think
over the pandemic there is no good
figures on this but you can kind of draw
some conclusions from the attack figures
unfortunately as to when about a dog
hits majority age and then we start to
see these attacks pick up in about 2021
and then really severely 2022 and um
even um this year as well so far
um I would pick up that uh as Ed says
they they were originally bred from
American Pit Bull Terriers and American
Staffordshire Terriers American
Staffordshire Terriers are different to
English Staffordshire bull terriers in
that um it's basically just a sanitized
name of the American Pit Bull Terrier in
the US that allows you to kind of um
I sign it up to official kennel clubs
under that kind of official name until
like the mid 70s so they were they were
taken from what is essentially a
fighting breed and in the U.S
dogfighting went on for a very long time
uh it was still legal in most places
until the mid 70s and um even in 2005
there was very little enforcement to
stop it and these dogs uh the largest of
these dogs were then bred with each
other and there were claims maybe some
Mastiffs were mixed in but that's not
actually easy to find it looks like a
lot of them are heavily Pitbull and they
are um bread and into bread
um and sometimes quite aggressively
inbred in order to get larger and larger
muscle mass and larger size so as where
a pit bull might max out about 20
kilograms and American Bully XL is
around about 60 kilograms
I mean it seems kind of remarkable that
this dog hasn't been banned yet I mean
Ed so the rsdca say on this we believe
focusing on the type of dog rather than
their individual actions as a flawed and
failing approach dog aggression is
highly complex and taking a breed
focused approach is fundamentally flawed
I mean what do you make of that is it is
it dog ownership or is it is it both and
a lot of this comes down to you know the
blank slate idea which is
um
sort of overwhelmingly dominant in in
Western Society generally this is a
denial of the genetic input into
personality
um which is very widespread about humans
um I mean we are in urban Society so
people who grow up in urban societies
are small families can kind of become
unaware of the fact that
um most in fact all traits are partly
hereditary so if you bread
any animal for certain traits repeatedly
those traits have become much more
extreme so dogs have been deliberately
bred this way so if you get aggressive
dogs and they may the rest dogs they're
going to become more aggressive over
time and it's the same with any dog I
mean I mentioned my own dog which is a
Portuguese Podengo I'm not a fan of I
have to say
um who's you know very very good with
kids as long as you're not a fox in
which case still kill your kids and you
know she's been very very well trained
and everything
um but she will always try to attack
small animals she's just at Hunter by
natural nature um and that's just
um the way it is so you can't really
just say oh you know a good
uh you know good owner will make these
dogs are aggressive because lots of the
fatalities have actually involved quite
you know pretty good owners who did all
the right things I mean the dog walkers
the classic example she was a perfectly
nostalgic yeah it was horrification she
tried to she warned other people to get
away whether it's supported there's all
this kind of stuff about oh you know
she's attacked by all these other dogs
those are Dachshunds maybe like a Cocker
person thing and it obviously didn't
make sense because you know that's just
even if the Jackson wants to attack you
it wouldn't be able to overpower you
um and these dogs have a very you know
it's a combination of both aggression
and Incredible strength
um with um so you know it's completely
flawed to just say it's the owner it's a
mixture of genetics and upbringing which
um which makes adult violent so so
Lawrence what do you think we can do
about this I mean can you ban a breed
like this or is it are these things very
easy to circumvent do they just mix them
with other kinds of dogs and that kind
of thing
yeah so um this is uh also a frequent
objection from um groups like The rspca
and others which is that one they claim
that breed doesn't matter and two if it
did matter which we can see from
statistics cross-culturally it does
um even if it does you can't do anything
about it the the problem with that is
that
um there are at least two different
routes which seem to be quite effective
we've banned Pitbull types actually not
just a Pitbull breed we banned Pitbull
types since 1991. because the government
hasn't updated the guidance on what
defines a pit bull
um and a pit bull types of all the
crosses and for instance American Bully
excels and American bullies probably
fall under this as well really
um the guidance if it was updated could
reflect this and these dogs just simply
wouldn't have been able to be imported
into the country originally the fact the
government hasn't updated the guidance
essentially created a loophole where
these dolls could then be imported
and now we see the effects and in fact
we can see how good and how effective
um Banning uh people types has been in
that the moment we get back a Pit Bull
type dog our attacks Skyrocket which
tells us that the dangerous dogs act
contrary to a lot of kind of opinion
seems to have worked pretty well for
quite a long time and keeping numbers
quite low
um the other option is if the government
doesn't want to update guidance they can
today at any point add the American
Bully Breed to the banned list
um through the signature of the
environment secretary it doesn't take
much time at all does that mean the dogs
are put down if that happens all right
um so the government has a list of
options that they can then uh pursue so
that would be you can do anything from
you can enforce leads and muzzles in
public uh neutering you can make sure
that people can't sell the dog so you
don't get like a breed uh people who are
breeders then have to either keep the
dogs
um or for instance people who currently
own them can't then sell them on they
have to keep them they have to look
after them they have to have them
neutered and muzzled in public the 1991
um band of pitbulls did have people have
to apply to courts to prove that their
dogs weren't dangerous of which by the
way actually a large number of dogs were
shown not to be dangerous and they could
keep them but there was about a thousand
dogs that the court saw which they said
were outwardly aggressive and were
deemed dangerous
um but the government has these kind of
options to hand if they pursued that
path
so it seems like there are options the
government hasn't acted yet do you think
this sort of ties into the very
deep-seated some British love and of
animals that we almost can't accept
sometimes that that some particular
types of dogs are being yeah I mean your
question was they're not going to kill
any dogs anything
by the way when 25 tin foils we're gonna
come and kill your dogs now
um I mean I I you know I'm a I'm a dog
skeptic I think they
obviously they bring a lot of droid
people but they're also they're kind of
a nuisance to people who don't want them
around and um but you know obviously I'm
out touch the Great British public here
who love dogs absolutely I think you
know I think inevitably this probably
will I think there will be legislation
one of the reasons that these dogs are
are obviously very dangerous to a lot of
other ducks and
um and of course you know a number of
deaths
um but yeah I mean I I think the British
are probably like the most sentimental
about animals you know there was like
Lawrence mentioned the million
signatures for that petition about those
two dogs that were shot in the East End
um which is looked like clearly that was
the right thing to do and yet they
learned the police you're on the police
path yeah but um you know obviously a
million people will disagree on that so
yeah and you mentioned I think I can't
let me finishing the CMP sorry but about
the fact that often these dogs are
marked as Nanny animals yeah half a
children can you tell us a bit about
that I mean I I actually got that from
Lawrence's piece and he goes into the
sort of myth of that and I think it was
sort of created in the 70s and I think
it was actually I know you're wrong it
was was actually about staffies
originally
um yeah and the sort of God I mean if
you look at these dogs as I mean these
look dogs look satanic like you would
obviously never let this this monster
need your children it's obviously really
really dangerous
um but yeah I just that's kind of a
testament to the I mean if you go to
Facebook there are all these kind of pit
bull mum kind of web you know like
groups where they talk about how amazing
their dogs are and you know nothing will
convince these people otherwise the dog
is actually quite you know a bit
dangerous
um so yeah I mean that's what you're
dealing with but I think you know it
sounds perfectly reasonable you know
that
you know Kevin Lee I mean I've seen
these dogs out in my local park I've
seen one which I'm pretty sure is and
it's off the lead and I think that's
unbelievably irresponsible and action
and people shouldn't have to fear being
attacked by a dog
um it's just kind of in a basic kind of
principle uh and you know if if they are
shouldn't be dangerous yeah and then
lead or you know or not allowed to you
know breed further which seems kind of
very reasonable to me I mean as
interesting Lawrence do you think the
sort of the sanctions on dog owners
should be harsher as well than than they
are at the moment if your dog does
attack someone
yeah and I think if your dog attacks
another dog
um just last week
um there was an average I think I think
every day there was a reported dog
attacked uh or actually killed by an
American Bully
um if we're talking about like
preserving other dogs
um these These dogs I mean they are bred
from dog fighting stock these were dogs
that were bred to fight other dogs which
um just goes to show that we shouldn't
be surprised if they are also uh
aggressive
um to dogs uh more generally as well as
the people and in terms of the the
sanctions on the owner I do think that
realistically we need to be much harsher
and much more
um close on enforcement there are some
rules in the dangerous dogs act at the
moment where if you allow your dog to
attack somebody and you know you haven't
gone on the sufficient control there are
actual uh penalties there but getting
the police to investigate or follow up
that's that's all incredibly difficult
and often in these kind of attacks that
happen in public uh the pattern seems to
be the dog runs off lead attack somebody
or another dog or kills another dog and
then runs off and the owner just leaves
so you know we we really need a better
way of enforcing this and really I think
adding some harsh penalties that make
people realize that uh having a powerful
dog means you have a big responsibility
over that animal
[Music]
thank you